for Global functions and pcps thank you
very much thank you all for coming for
this final talk
so
in the previous two talks we talked
about what are you in games
and how is analysis related to it and we
finished by stating this
statement for the agreement for the
soundness of the Glassman test and we
showed we showed only One Direction but
which only this is true if and only if
some expansion theorem calls for the
last manga so I was debating what to do
in this talk and eventually I decided
that it would be good if I gave you some
sense of why this expansion Shield is
true so I'm not going to give you the
full profits I don't have enough votes
but uh anyway I'll give you some sense
to why this is true and then talk a
little bit more generally about what is
the global hyper connectivity and what
it is good for besides pcps
so it's like oh
yeah
so we denoted by
uh the set of suspices
dimension
in f210
and you should also think about it as
denoting the government graph itself
namely we have also the set of edges
which are between another time if they
intersect in dimension wonders
so let's recall what was the expansion
field you know so we need definition
so if I have a set of vertices
then it is called are Epsilon global
so I also do unknown so I'm going to use
these two terms interchangeably
if
whenever I take this small set that
doesn't expand the test Dimension at
most hour so for every Subspace X
and W inside F2 down
well the dimension of X is small and the
core dimension of WX model
it holds that s is not very dense inside
out
okay so this is what we call a global
set and with this in mind the expansion
theorem in the gas and graph says
that for every
zero
there will be some Arrow
and Delta
so that's a bit if I response that
which is global
then
the expansion of this
is first one
well let me remind you that the
expansion of Earth is the probability
that when I choose random vertex for
mass then to economy
by escapists
so
so now we are going to devote a chunk of
time to get some sense to why this
Theory restore of course as I said I'm
not going to give you the full post but
I hope that you'll get some idea of why
this is true
okay
so the main benefit of working with such
a statement about sets as opposed to a
statement about some assignments is that
you know a set is a blown function
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to define a Boolean function
which is just the indicator of the set
foreign
and once we do that we can start
applying specular tools to study the
function
and this is what we're going to do and
you'll see a bunch of things that were
already mentioned in several other talks
for example the first thing that I'm
going to tell you is that there exists
this degraded composition which is
really the same as what Max discussed in
stock
so I'm not going to to you know pull
things too formally but I hope that
there will be some sense in it
a degree composition
so whatever you want to mention to
Define some notion of degree it's best
to think of you know the simplest thing
that you would like to call a degree
function which is a hunter has not
mentioned in stocks and then take a
spanner and this will give you a nice
notion of liquidity so with this in mind
if we have
so
if we look at the set x a Subspace
let us Dimension at most d
then we can look at the indicators
function of containing s and this will
be referred to as a dehunta
no because it really depends on whether
I contain some D vectors or not
so now to Define degrees I can just take
a span of this
so if I want to define the space of the
most D functions this is going to be
denoted by J at most d
I'm going to Define it to be the spanner
of all of these indicators
something so good
so just in just as in Max talk this is
not going to give me a nice orthogonal
decomposition because you know enjoy
yesterday I have also the D minus one
functions it D minus two functions and
so on and I want to sort of fall them
away
so we do the same thing
we Define the set of pure degree
functions to be the great mostly
functions the pelvis diagonal
degrees most D minus one functions
so throughout I'm going to think of the
inner product space which is f times G
with expectation
over l
so
so this is a function this is a function
that the input hello
and output one
if x is containing error
so L is the input of the function
X
a fixed X and now we Define a function
over suspices the function output one if
and only if the Subspace contains
okay
any more questions
another one
[Music]
yeah so now I'm
justifiably said that you know this
functions really correspond to one
one of the types of non-globalness that
we have which this x is
you could have justifiably said okay
what about dictators like indicate of L
containing some hyperplane so maybe not
type of way maybe something of what I
mentioned it must be
it's an exercise to show that
if W is a hyperplane of correlation one
then you can write this as a sum of
these things for X of Dimension One
so actually the two definitions are the
same
but this kind of Duality is
this is the first sign that
complicated things could happen because
you have to choose a basis one of them
but then somehow your argument is going
to take care of both of them together
because this is a statement that is
concerned with both of them
but anyway I'm getting out of myself but
thank you now for this question
okay
cool so we have all of these spaces out
of the way and then you can just say
that all of your real evalued functions
on the gas and graph
a result of direct sum of these spaces
oh
okay in other words if I ever make
function f which is the indicator so
maybe that's for listening we only have
one
so if we look at our function f from the
beginning then we can just decomposite
according to this decomposition
foreign
spaces you can compute the dimensions
but we don't want to do any of that all
that we're going to care about is that
when you look at the adjacency Matrix
of the customer graph then the spaces
are actually again spaces
so this is a fact
let's
see
the normalized
efficiency
synthetics
so here's the start
and started cheating what never mind
space
is
agit space
foreign
value
the minus I that's maybe something small
okay
so I just want to say because I don't
want to completely cheat so you may say
that you may have observe that his
faults because the price of the is zero
and these are positive numbers so how
can it be so the point is that for I
which is equal to l this is not actually
correct my back universe is very small
we don't it's a negative small number
that we don't care about but with this
out of the way let's pretend that this
is true
so now we have our function f we have
our decomposition and we know something
about the eigenvalues so now we're just
going to express expansion in terms of
this decomposition and see what we get
foreign
[Music]
minus the expansion
then you can this is the function of
edges that stay inside this events
so you can write it as one of the
measure of s
times zainability between F and
digestion operator apply domain
because
this counts the number of edges that are
inside s once you start with something
inside us
so now we plug in this decomposition and
we use diagonal values
and get so I'm going to ignore this
liquid of one together this is equal to
one of them Us times summation from I
equals zero
well 2 to the minus I
times
Let's do an almost by five
right here we use the fact that f i and
fjlth we used
and we got a nice expected
expression for our expansion
okay
so this by itself is not going to buy
you much but you can already see
something which is known to even
which is going to motivate
similar to this theorem
so here is a statement which is very
simple
foreign
close to one expansion and the weakest
form of pseudo-anomas that you can think
about is just the set being small like
nothing about this
x and double
so here's what smallness buys you
okay
then
the expansion of us is to be at least
somewhat loudly
at least half mine looks a little bit
Okay so
let's move it
okay can anybody tell me the proof not
Norm
Ally
constant part is
yeah exactly
so we're going to use Style
so as Mark said we're going to separate
out I equals 0 because their diagonal
value is not so good it's just one
and we're going to use the fact that we
actually know what F0 is
F0 is a constant function it is the
constant function which is closest to f
and normally just its average
so by Style
okay let's do it slowly this is F0
plus summation I from one
well to go by next I
times squared
so as we said this is the measure so one
over mules
so as we said
F0 is just a measure of s so it's two
Norm is the measure of x squared
so we get mu of s
from the first die
and what about the other thing well each
one of these eigen values it must have
this is only all I'm going to use
so plus 1 over 2 mu fifths
time summation iPhone 1 12 between over
five yes I squared
and now we're going to use password
value so we know that the sum of all of
the two Norms of fi is the two Norm of f
therefore the sum this incomplete sum is
equal to the two Norm of f squared minus
the two numbers F 0 squared
which is just
minus mu of s
ort so we plug it in
we simplify and we get that this is
equal to let's see
um half
uh mu of s over two
so now we will arrange it and you get
disclaimer
foreign
so this is very simple we didn't really
do anything but at least writing down
this line This suggests
how you are going to get Beyond half
so the reason that we got this half
expansion is because below again value
half there is only one in there is only
one function and we know what to say
about the component there
so if we could say something interesting
about not only F0 but also F1
then it stands to reason that you are
going to push Beyond this quarter it is
a
half and the higher we're going to
decrease the better this is going to get
so in other words if
we knew
when you look at f i
to Norm of it is it most some small
Epsilon times the measure of s
then you can sort of this argument
concatable thing below so forever I
listening
oh
then you can repeat this argument
everything below are you take together
in order the master is small just
because of this everything above it
while you're going to use stronger
boundary angle value it's going to be to
the minus now
and it's going to improve
so if you check out the mouth this is
what you would get you would get that
the expansion is very close to one as
long as Alex official then Epsilon is
small
so now we look at this
thing and
this is really the same as the level the
O Level I inequality that now mentions
and if we had this level the inequality
in this case then we'd be done
but then we'd also not use globalness
so this has to fail
so now the question is
when can we say that we only have low
mass on the low levels
in other words they still introduces to
the following the equivalent result
agreement
for every episode
[Music]
if
yes
please
I'll get the global
Then Fall
really good of it
we have that
the mass one level
first for all I invest now
foreign
so I hope that it is clear that in order
to prove the expansion theorem now it
suffices to pull this type of level the
inequality which has a different Global
then indeed your mass on the low levels
is small
and I'm not as I said I'm not going to
pull it but I'm going to give you some
sense to why this is true in the
simplest case let's still give some idea
which is the case that
l equals one
so this is the simplest case but still
far from previous
so let's look at that one
so the first thing that we need is
actually some nice format for it
and this formula is going to look very
much like the formula that Max was
suggesting which is we take some
function of the points and then you
apply the applicator on it so this is
really what's going to happen
so it turns out that there exists a
function Little X
plus one
assigns to each point some real number
such that to evaluate capital F of PL
what you do is you sum up all of the
points inside there and you take the
value of later f of x
so this is a formula
and actually there is one important
additional feature of it which is I can
I can actually tell you what this little
f is
1 of x
so I'm slightly cheating with the
normalization but forgive me
so little f 1 of X is the difference in
measures in the set s
when you look at its measure overall and
its measure when you restrict yourself
to containing X
so this notation means the probability
that L is inside s
condition on X being in Arrow
so this is somewhat of a good sign
because at least somewhere in the
picture there is the density of s inside
this so-called zoomings so it seems like
we're going in the right direction but
we're still not there
foreign
so let's assume that it's false
let's assume that we have a lot of Mass
on F1
what if
so what if this happens well this means
that you have this degree one function
and it is correlated with a buoyant
function
you can observe that the two numbers
F1 is the same as the network in F and
F1
this is just a orthogonality
so you have a degree one function which
is called a Boolean function so let's
you know let's push things already level
one so let's say that somehow magically
F1 itself is Boolean valid
because you know these sort of things
are if you according to Williamson he
sort of suggested you have some boy and
bevel so let's push it to the extreme
so how could this sound be a Boolean
function
so
so let's think about it so now we're
going to think of things as random
variables
so let's suppose that
we choose Southwest error randomly and
then we look at the points in it
then this F150 is kind of a sum of
random variables
and to me this random variables seem
independent
right it's a bunch of points in some
space why not
and we know that if you have a sum of
independent variables then it's not
going to be Boolean it's going to be
some gaussian looking thing
but we know that this is not reduction
in a quick thing so how could it be the
case
well there are two options
foreign
is very small
and then this is going to be poisson
like kind of available and then maybe
it's Boolean
but in order for there to be a poisson
type Behavior it means that most of this
little f1s of X have to be zero and the
rest have to be very loud
foreign
and when I say a few so you can check
out the numbers because L contains
tutorial points a few here is
an example of the order of two to n
minus l
yes I'm being very informal I'm not
going to go into any more formalities
than that
but I came with this in this option
we're done
so why is that well we have a formula
for F1 of x
and
we got the difference between this
measure and this measure is loud
inside
the link of X is loud
and why not so long
foreign
so this is option one and it seems like
Okay sounds feasible but then you don't
see these type of plants anywhere
so there must be another option
so we call that I said that F1 is a sum
of independent looking things and I sort
of said it quickly so that no one asks
me about it
and the reason is that okay maybe
they're not independent so you know
Subspace is not an arbitrary set there's
a structure
so clearly if we have three points
in the Subspace
then for free we're going to get an
additional point we're going to get that
X Plus y but Z is awesome
so this says that there are possible
correlations like four escalations
anymore
so open two
foreign
X
oh
and if you do this carefully what you
actually get is that they have this
correlation in
Four Points
and when you normalize correctly what
you're going to get is that 2 to the
three L times the expectation of x y z
the product of four values
foreign
and you know even Norms are nicer
because you don't have absolute values
so this is why you're going to get four
escalations
maybe you can get through your
exploration but I don't know how to work
with odd moments
with absolutely
yeah but this is this is the only reason
so this is the second option now you
have this very nice looking term that if
you have done any four-way analysis in
your life then this screams expand me
according to the Fourier basis
so now if you think of F1 of x
please
and you expanded the code into the
Fourier basis
so expand it and you get it it was one
of X is equal to summation over s
so four coefficients
s of x
you plug it in and you get something
very nice
you get that
maybe let's do it here
so when you do this calculation like you
plug in the full expansion of Earth and
do expectation you're going to get it to
the field
times sum of four coefficients to the
fourth
constant
and once you do the standard stuff you
know pull scores out and handle the rest
by possible you're going to get it there
is one significant Fourier coefficient
at least one
very nice form of F1 so you can figure
out what the foil coefficients of the
hour and when you do it you're going to
get it still exists some hyper thing
well s is significantly done so
okay
so this is really roughly speaking the
quote for the degree one case
and you know if you sit down to do it
precisely it's not even that hard
but
you can imagine that once you go up in
the degrees it's going to get
complicated and it isn't all complicated
but it's not the end of the world but
this is really the way that
at least ideally
sir
so we're assuming that needs to fails
yeah therefore we have a lot of mass
on the first level
so what is the first ever Mass it's the
correlation between F1 and F itself
so this assumption really says that F1
is correlated with function
so for Simplicity we said replace the
word correlated with Boolean Behavior
but it's not really a big issue like
once you transfer everything to
Performance you don't see the difference
this is just for intuition yeah
foreign
dependency
right so somebody may feel interested
that if things are independent and not
too loudly magnitude it's going to be
the option
so this kind of well you have two
options
sorry
this yeah
so this is actually here I did a cloud
actually so when you plug this 4X
function you're only going to you're
going to be at four four coefficients
but 12 non-zero contribution they all
have to be the same
because
this one
here's another one
yeah
what's the intuition for why this
implies the hyperplane
so
that is only zoom out
so once you have a function that
measures how dense you get points
obsessed always
is going to measure closeness in like a
increase in what is dual points which
are hypotense
you can just actually compute it it's
not hello
any more questions
also think of the conditioner so
added energy
one this one yeah
um
this is the you know little f is not
I mean it's not a set it's a way value
company yeah so what do you mean by
this this expression for additive energy
you have a function with high additive
energy yeah
they are known classical results I'm
wondering with that Viewpoint maybe what
looks like your light reputation why
would you book a paper
that was the idealities well known they
didn't say that this it is anything
special but
you don't need so we usually when you
use this balance some of this stuff it's
for how things this is very simple so
what I said it's one line communication
part
okay
cool
so I hope that I convince you why these
two minutes for five equals one and you
sort of get the same for teaching little
general
foreign
this was you know motivated by PCP but
then you can take a step back and ask
yourself okay
we saw this expansion feelings and blah
blah it was very hecky we got some
expansion results we used for PCP but is
this expanded like theorems more general
or is it you know something very
specific to Glassman and you cannot do
anything else with it
and it turns out that it's actually
quite General phenomenon so it already
so few examples in this both count about
such places and I'm going to mention
them again in maybe a few more
thank you
so following this gasman stuff the first
thing that we looked at together with
Kia to give us non-man liquids and our
long is the simplest possible case you
can think of which is the p-bus cube
so I'm going to add four expected
I want to avoid some annoying
technicalities so I'm really going to
just think of the about the people ask
you but everything that I'm going to say
generalizes
so let's think of zero one today with
the p by X measure
let's be smaller
so we all defined a graph over this
vertex set which is the noisy graph so
let me say it again so let's
foreign
X
we're going to sample enable
by keeping
each code into the probability of
otherwise the example in it
according to me
important
okay
so you can look at this graph and you
can observe this is also not responsible
expander
part of the same movements
which is all of the points X
say X17 is equal to one
measure of s
but then expansion of this
and such
okay so it's not a sponsored expander so
again you can ask
although this is the only type of sets
that you want to expand well and yeah
this is true so kill him
definition
so let's
go
we have some global
it's where we see
of size responsibility
foreign
okay so this is really the analog of
what is happening on the gas
and the proof of physics is you know
much simpler okay
I'm not going to discuss it at all
but you know because we're working with
a simple space you can be more greedy
and ask okay this is muscle expansion
can you get something that looks really
like hyper connectivity
and the answer is yes
so
you know
so first of all you can pull a statement
about real valid functions
so
if you have a function
build value
so here I need to define a different
notion of globality so earlier we said
something about the measure of s not
being too large inside the domain
and this is going to be the same except
the measure is going to be replaced by
two normal
so by this I mean that expectation oh
that's x squared
information on x i equals one
if most Epsilon
however I've studied muscle
and that is lovely green
of something that that resembles
hyperconductivity
foreign
[Music]
and you can actually go further you can
give a statement that doesn't talk about
globality at all but give some weighted
average of what happens when you do this
restrictions so I don't want to do it
it's just a night it's just a formula
which is going to look complicated but
this exists
sorry
Epsilon to the half F2 to the half
so
so in hyper connectivity you would
expect like the two Norm of f here
but here you have to replace one of
these Norms by this alarms what's the
exponent
so yeah
the geometric mean of global experiments
sorry
foreign
[Music]
look at more complicated situations and
I'm not going to Define anything but I'm
going to tell you that there are analogs
of it for stuff like it does some graph
which is not a product space but it kind
of looks like workspace so things do
work out
yeah you just prove it by I mean using
small size expansion the hyper
connectivity and then I mean like yeah
and then the noise operator applied to F
kind of maintains This Global property
so like every is it the case that every
object you encounter in the proof is
global and so you can assume it like
that you're acting by on a small side
effect
um no so the pool police actually mimics
the the usual profile connectivity very
much so
okay so there are several of this one of
them is you can write a different
statements for this which channelizes
and then you can do induction
another thing you can do is actually
reduce this statement to some statement
queue by using something like the
replacement Network
so you can expand your function
according to the pbiased basis you can
look with the phone on then you can
slowly replace this device
can you see what you get and if you do
it quality this is what you get but it's
not the
um
this again
so in other words you cannot go from the
preceding theorem to this oh yes it's
not the way around
[Music]
and you can also prove it directly there
are many things
no
um it's the down up walk on the complete
hyper like the complete complex
[Music]
yes
that also gets some stuff like that for
animation expansions so I don't want to
be funny because I don't have
at five minutes and
I'll say something more
anyway so there are a few other cases
you know what he's known but for me what
is more interesting is that each one of
these instances gives you some nice
application
so you know proving this sort of stuff
for fun it's good but
it's nice to know that it's good with
something
so what is it good for
so we already solve if it's good for PCP
foreign
there is some extension of filming again
which is called please do one games well
it is also useful and I believe there
will be a few more applications to PCP
but oops
secondly
today is the reason that we look at the
earbuds Cube to start with you have
applications to chart thresholds
so you know if you have a starting
device Cube which is one of them you can
start asking how quickly does it ever
jump when I increase speed
so for most functions it's going to
increase very quickly and you would like
to say if it doesn't increase quickly
then it's because I have some extraction
inequalities
so thirdly and this is the thing now
we're going to discuss a little bit
in his talk which is coming up next is
you can use it for Human coming products
so you're going to talk about product
specs inside
so
so you have that you can prove a bunch
of results in excellent to Windows which
otherwise seem kind of portable but
because the extremely examples resemble
this type of says they don't expand you
have some chance that this sort of
Machinery will help and it's always to
be the case that this is true many times
yeah
so fourth
it is also useful it's available codes
and testing the model core
so I don't have enough time so I'm not
going to tell you what the problem is
exactly maybe
so the form is exposed
attention selection today
and I know that locally it looks like a
degree function
then if I look at the Subspace
of dimension
difference one
then the degree of the Restriction of f
must be
close to 14.
this means that itself has to be close
to D2D
well that's what turns out to be yes and
if you want to prove it
and get nice bounds this sort of goes is
also are also useful
so these are just four type of problems
well this sort of tools come in handy
and I believe there will be more areas
and this is part of the motivation for
me to present to you this actually look
for other connections with between
Global hypertility and other areas
Norm suggested already
so things that we didn't think about at
all so that's it thank you
[Applause]
any questions for those
foreign
chance that it could work with and it
could be very nice but we don't know it
it's also worth mentioning that this uh
yeah so it didn't specify what the
result okay this it builds on like many
walks right
very sweet
any more questions
but
foreign